jordan Spieth is the most popular man in
the world right now this man won the
Masters this weekend and he is most
known for his short game Jordan we are
joined by our boss Mike floors a golf
enthusiast we thought since we have you
here put your work I mean sure it's on a
media tour we could do a little work yes
I'd love to make point this out I have a
better chance the next decade of
shooting my age than he does you got
that right all right here's our Mike all
right how would you advise them here
well I'd like to see something first
okay here we go you ready oh how good is
that oh well you got to get it there
Salish
oh I know that so Jordan here you are it
was a good role this weekend when you
were in this position help us understand
what goes through your mind at this
moment well I left myself with some
tough putts but just tried to have an
imagination tried to really it's all
about speed which we're obviously
struggling with here right now but
having a hard time with speed you know
he's not used to the green there it is
every putt Oaks been perfect it needs no
help it's just greens that they
obviously didn't speed the greens up
this morning that's exactly right
it's not on you it's not they cut it
earlier there it is again how good is
that understand when you're in this
moment like Mike is truly though how do
you handle the pressure and not choke
yes you could say you yoga breathe
you've got meditation how do you handle
it you really yes I mean there is
breathing techniques that definitely
help but ultimately you really have to
focus on the whole you can't think about
anything don't look at the scoreboard
don't don't think about it being for
birdie for par for bogey it doesn't even
matter
point is is you have to know recognize
get the read think about the speed and
just pretend like you're just hitting
another putt on the practice green and
and it's easier said than done but when
you hit enough of them under pressure
you start to see something go in there's
great visualization that you can take
from that and you take some confidence
just from watching it how often do you
look at the hole when you're putting as
opposed to the ball you know yeah it's a
weird technique that I do I do it from
short range normally four feet in and I
look at a very specific point on the
front edge of the hole and look see you
should it's not the worst idea right you
just can't miss that you can't miss
senses where does mental strength come
from within a lot of it is based on
again just seeing something prior to
prior to doing it having seen putts go
in but as far as mental strength I mean
that's just something that I guess you
just develop over time with with success
Mike you've been an animal since the
start absolutely
where do you get your your advise in
this kid he's 21 years old clearly he
needs to stay grounded
we know that Tiger Woods so he's
compared to all the time and some issues
around staying grounded how would you
advise him well he should enjoy life is
just working but you also got to
understand you're only as good as your
last game and the last championship and
there are lots of other players out
there and people want somebody who's
sympathetic who's interested in helping
kids I watched Bubba Watson one time I
was playing with him in a ProAm and he's
about to hit and some kids said mr.
Watson can I have a signature he stopped
and he walked over and he signed the kid
about missing a step
smiling and everybody in the audience
fell in love with Bubba Watson right
there because he didn't snap at the kid
he was there representing golf
representing himself representing his
sponsors and he handled himself like a
real gentleman that's what you got to do
does your family play in your golf Oh a
lot yeah I mean they're they made
sacrifices back to when I was really
young just to take me to the course I'd
go wake them up at 7 in the morning
saying hey mom
drive me to the course my buddies are
getting out there before me and then
they still continue to to offer that
kind of support and do whatever I need
to to have this success I mean they're
the reason I Michael and I were given
the opportunity on the course this past
week to accomplish a dream is that who
you play for your family yeah definitely
I play for my family I play for a lot I
play for a lot of people but most
importantly my family I'm nothing to be
here with to extort a favorite golfer
not today older golfer who would you who
would you look to and say they had the
perfect swing there's a Hogan
Sam Snead swings hard to beat when you
look at it but at Ben Hogan
I like the Texas Legends as well of
Nelson and Hogan and and who they were
off the course as well you know that's
that's kind of who I strived to be if I
could get my elbow in like Hogan I could
be with you in the next sleek and putt
just find that didn't seem to be a
problem